Oh
you know if I have to verbalize what I
believe accounts for the failure of most
of my romantic relationships is the fact
that I cannot bear loves aging I cannot
stand the dissolution of the honeymoon
phase right as soon as the vacation the
electrifying vitality the rapture of
meeting someone new phase it's a kind of
death practice you die a little
when enthronement dissipates you kind of
have a moment of profound tragic
realization that everything passes that
our greatest ecstasy's are imbued are
cast upon by a shadow of dread of
knowing that this will pass that this
will
and so what do we do when we look into
the iris of a lover's eye right when
being seen by the person you love so
much gives you goosebumps makes you cry
touches your core touches your soul
titillate everything inside of you makes
you think of that role in Barth's books
lovers discourse about how the cradling
that takes place between two people when
they finally feel safe like Adam and Eve
in the Garden of Eden before the tree of
knowledge before knowledge of death and
the transience was known see I want to
live in that Garden of Eden I fantasize
about it i watch movies about it I
listen to beautiful songs about it but
curiosity killed the cat I ate from the
tree of knowledge I learned about death
and mortality and endings and entropy
and I think that that has haunted all of
my relationships this this this terror
of the inevitable ending and I'm still
dealing with finding a hack for that
that's the truth